-Oh, this is interesting here.
I read that more cats are
becoming therapy animals.
Yeah. Cats.
-Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Whoa!
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's crazy. Crazy.
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Please. Please, sit down.
Sorry. I'm sorry. Sorry.
-Oh, my God, Jimmy.
What are you doing?
You're doing jokes about cats?
Therapy animals.
Are you serious right now?
-Did someone lose their child?
I'm sorry.
-All right.
-That's just great, Jimmy.
That's really great.
-I'm kidding.
You guys, my good friend and our
co-host Kevin Hart is here!
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jimmy makes me laugh.
You really make me laugh, Jimmy.
-Thank you.
-"Did someone lose their child?"
-That's a good one.
-Really?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-A short joke, Jimmy?
That's how original you are?
-Yeah, that's right.
-Look at you.
Just look at you.
Has anybody told you that
you got a big head, Jimmy?
Like a big head.
-Really?
-I'm not talking about your ego.
I'm just talking about
an enormous sized head.
-Oh, what?
-You know they had to create
an IMAX just for the two movies
that he made?
There's two. There's two movies.
-All right, yeah.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-I remember them. Yeah.
My movie career
doesn't compare to yours.
-No, no.
-But let me ask.
You've made so many films
in the last few years.
Have you ever thought
of just slowing down
and making just one good one?
-Oh. Oh.
-Just think of it.
-Oh, gosh.
[ Rimshot ]
Quest! Quest!
-No, no, no, I'm kidding.
We're buddies.
I'm serious. I'm so happy
that you're co-hosting tonight.
I really appreciate you
saying yes
after Dwayne Johnson said no.
-Okay. You know what?
-That -- That --
That meant something to me.
-You're not going to
hurt my feelings, Jimmy.
I'm not going to let you hurt my
feelings. I'm gonna be honest.
I'm actually really excited
to be here tonight.
Jimmy, your show reminds me
of every birthday party
I've ever went to when I was 12.
Uh, here's my question.
When do we play spin-the-bottle
with Oprah
and Ruth Bader Ginsburg?
-All right. That's actually
not a bad idea. I would do that.
-But honestly, Jimmy,
you're amazing.
You know what you're like?
Jimmy, Jimmy, you're like
the pumpkin-spice latte.
See? You're a little too sweet,
but the white people love you.
It's one of those weird things.
It's one of those things.
[ Laughter ]
Pow-pow-pow-pow!
-Pow-pow-pow-pow-pow!
-Pow. Wow.
You pow'd me on that one.
-After I got to follow
Jimmy around all day,
I realized, dude,
you got an easy job.
This is an easy job
in show business.
-What are you --
What are you talking about?
-What do you mean, what
am I talking about, Jimmy?
All you do is read jokes
off cue cards. That's it.
-Come on.
My job's not that easy.
-Jimmy, you just read that
off of a cue card.
That's what you just --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And tell me. Why is every
late-night host named Jimmy?!
Why? Like, what kind of
grown man is named Jimmy?
Might as well be named Skippy.
Let's go through it.
Let's through the names.
You got Jimmy Fallon.
You got Jimmy Kimmel.
-That's right.
-You got James Corden.
He's basically a Jimmy.
-That's true. All right.
-If I change my name
to Jimmy Hart,
my question is,
can I have a talk show?
-Absolut-- Tonight,
you can have half of one.
You ready to do this?
-I am ready to do it, Skippy.
-All right. Let's go.
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots!